When it comes to neighboring countries, many countries have several options: like Canada to the north.
South to Mexico
But some countries do not have such free choices; not because they are island countries
But because they are trapped by other countries. For example, the Vatican City State.
It is not only surrounded by Italy, but also surrounded by a city of Rome.
How the Vatican City is trapped is very complicated, but not special; there is also the Republic of San Marino:
30,000 residents are also surrounded by Italy. Obviously, Italy
It is a country that likes the country in its own country.
But the country is not an Italian patent. There is also Lesotho in South Africa.
It is the largest country in China: 70 times larger than the Vatican
Also the largest population: more than two million people
What makes the borders of these three countries strange is any access
Going through their only neighbours
But look at the Gambia: except for the small coastline, it is also a country.
Completely surrounded
If we add any "land" access to the previous definition, we will now make a category of "countries of a single neighbouring country".
Including the four countries just now, as well as Portugal, its only
Access to and from the passage through Spain. Who else is in that category?
Well, there are Monaco by France, Qatar via Saudi Arabia, Denmark.
Through Germany, South Korea via North Korea (although South Korea can be regarded as
An island country, if you want to actually travel)
East Timor and Papua New Guinea via Indonesia, Brunei via Malaysia
And two pairs of brothers: the only neighbor of the Dominican Republic
Is Haiti, and Haiti’s only neighbour is the Dominican Republic.
The second pair is: Ireland through the United Kingdom and the United Kingdom
Ireland.
Small description:
Although there are many British territories in the world, some are bordered by other countries.
-- They are not part of the UK. This is very complicated
But you can argue that Britain is under the strait
Dig an underground passage boundary to the European continent, I hope to have closer contact with France, her best
friend
Finally, there is one more country in this category: Canada: the largest in the world and only one neighbor
country.